you
I've been traveling you know as the
frugal traveler for four or five years
now and I think when it started I was
maybe a little bit more willing to put
up with certain hardships um terrible
places to stay for instance i still like
a bad place to stay every once in a
while now but i really appreciate having
not just a shower but a hot shower uh
having a decent bed to sleep in those
are nice things I really like them now I
can still I can still go without food or
go with bad food I can you know walk 15
miles a day and not worry about it i can
be in on some sweaty uncomfortable buses
but it's nice to have a place to stay
that that you're happy to be there so
that's it yeah I just want to I want to
I want to sleep a little better I want
to be comfortable good maybe I'm old now
maybe I'm old that's what happens
travel they don't know what's actually
important to them often you have a mix
of travelers in a group and some people
really care about the hotel that they're
staying and some people really care
about the food other people want to
spend a lot of money on shopping so
people want to spend a lot of money and
museums and those are all different
priorities um and people wind up
spending a lot of money because they're
not really sure what their priorities
are until they get somewhere and they
think that a lot of money has to go
towards everything but if you say look
all I really care about is shopping of
you know buying clothes buying books
buying chacha cos whatever then hey you
know what if that's what's important to
me then maybe I don't need to spend that
much on the hotel I don't need to spend
that much on getting there I don't need
to eat anywhere besides maybe street
food or some small easy restaurants
focusing the money focusing what your
priorities are is really the way to to
save money and to avoid blowing it on
things that you don't actually care
about but it takes time it takes a lot
of experience traveling to figure out
what you actually care about I mean
you're not going to know going to a
place like Bangkok or or Sydney or
wherever you're not going to know what
you actually want to do on your first
trip it's only with time you know after
years and dozens of trips that you say
you know I don't really care about you
know going to fancy restaurants anymore
and so I'm not going to spend money on
that
food food I mean if I you know if I had
to devote eighty percent of my budget to
one thing it would be food but that is
necessarily mean that I want to eat in
fancy places it just means that the the
experience of eating is what's most
important to me and so you know if it's
a street stall with a great bowl of
noodles or if it's you know a really
great restaurant you know with two
Michelin stars up in the mountains
that's totally inaccessible otherwise
those are the things that are important
to me and the price for them is
something that I'm willing to pay
wherever I go because I want that
experience I've started again as I said
I've started to spend a bit more when it
comes to hotels just because I'm tired
of being tired but it's still a lower
priority for me but food I mean food is
is is what i'm most excited about when i
travel and so you know if i'm spending
three euros or if i'm spending you know
fifty thousand yen on the meal that's
that's what I'm gonna go for it but I
also wanted to be worthwhile you know
I'm going to spend you know three
hundred dollars a person on a meal it
should be a good meal
back in in 1996 and 1997 I used to live
in in Ho Chi Minh City Vietnam the
former Saigon and while I was there I
had a pretty standard lunch routine
there was a place near my little mini
apartment that did pretty good grilled
pork chops on rice that's really popular
South Vietnamese lunch and I just had
that all the time and it was it was
quite good I loved it um and then on a
trip back to Vietnam I think about six
years ago a friend of mine took me to a
restaurant called Gil yang that
specializes in this grilled pork chop on
rice and it just it totally blew
everything out of the water that I ever
had before I it was the biggest juiciest
most perfectly grilled and caramelized
and flavorful porkchop I've ever had on
really excellently cooked rice they use
a thing called broken rice which is
broken grains of rice is very sort of
peasant ething this is perfectly cooked
and it was just I mean it was it was the
memories that I'd had of eating my good
standard lunch every day back in in the
late 90s were just completely forgotten
because this one pork chop so sweet and
and and charcoal II and juicy had
destroyed everything else so it makes it
hard then to eat this stuff again
elsewhere because there's the memory of
the great one I had that happened in in
Galicia northwestern Spain they make
this octopus pupo la gallega which is
really simple it's just long boiled
octopus um they boil it perfectly they
slice it up they drench it in good olive
oil crunchy salt and pimentón the sort
of smoked chili powder not spicy but
it's very smoky sweet flavor and I had
it with some some dark bread and this
little bar and it was just so totally
amazing
and perfectly cooked that it couldn't
eat octopus again for months and months
after that because nothing could
possibly be as good as this one thing at
this little bar in this little town near
the coast so I always watch out for
these these great meals because they
tend to ruin the future you want really
really good meals you want to eat at a
high level every day and not just um you
know not not at all true exceptional
level but a very high level because the
ultra exceptional will love will make
everything pale in comparison and then
you know you disappointed and crabby
because nothing's ever as good as that
yeah then you start talking about how
you had this octopus inglesi and
northwestern span and you sound like a
douche